Speaker 1: Donald Trump had a rally on
Saturday in Nevada and at this rally,
his brain genuinely appeared to
malfunction and break. He talked
about a Chinese restaurant bowling alley
at which documents were reportedly stored,
as if it somehow means that what he did
with his documents at Mar a Lago is okay.
Listen to this story that Trump told.
Speaker 3: George H.W. Bush took millions
of documents to a former bowling alley
and a former Chinese restaurant where
they combined them. So they're in a
bowling alley slash Chinese restaurant.
Speaker 1: Now. What's the truth of the story?
The truth is that when the National Archives
is participating in the process of the creation
of a presidential library, they will often
rent or lease some space wherever the library is
being built or close to where they are working.
And it is true that the National Archives, NARA,
they leased what was essentially a warehouse to
temporarily store documents for George H.W. Bush
in College Station, Texas. It was a building that
at one point was a bowling alley, and part of the
building was a Chinese restaurant. Trump wants to
frame it as George H.W. Bush took a whole bunch
of documents, just like Trump did, and put them at
what was at the time a functioning bowling alley
or Chinese restaurant. That's not what happened.
Nara, properly in control of documents, leased the
space that used to be that it has no connection
whatsoever to what Donald Trump did. And every
one of these stories has like a kernel of truth
wrapped in 99% lies Trump going on during this
speech about when are they going to prosecute
Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton and all of them?
Speaker 3: I believe that. What do you think?
Yes. Yes, Mike. When will they investigate
and prosecute Bill Clinton, Hillary Clinton,
George Bush? A look into what took
place with George Bush's father,
a very nice man, and the warehouse of
documents. And. What about Barack Hussein
Obama? Obama? The potential prosecution?
I don't think so. I don't think they are
a Chinese restaurant and a bowling alley.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Trump just focusing
on they should all be prosecuted. Of course,
they didn't do any of the things that Donald
Trump did. Trump also fixating on Bill Clinton
and a sock drawer, but he pronounces it a sock
drawer. It's a it's it's very interesting.
Speaker 3: They're still looking for those
pages. Bill Clinton took millions of documents
from the White House to a former car dealership
in Arkansas. We love Arkansas. I can tell you. We
want Arkansas both times also and kept classified
recordings in his sock drawer.
Speaker 1: Sock drawer.
Speaker 3: In fact, he supposedly put the
information from the White House into his socks.
Speaker 1: These rallies are so insane. At another
point, Trump very dangerously bragged about how
big the crowd was on January six, 2021, as if
that's something to cheer about, given the hell
and destruction that that crowd unleashed.
But the crowd in Nevada seems to like it.
Speaker 3: And these corrupt people
will never take a camera and turn it
around and show them how many people are
here. They never do it. They're corrupt.
They never do it. You know, I never knew the
cameras because this took place. Right. And they
never want to show how massive a crowd was.
You know, the biggest crowd I've ever seen,
January six. And you never hear that.
Speaker 1: And the crowd loves it. By the way,
at these rallies, the crowd constantly is
booing and and sort of jeering the media at
the back of the rally. The only media at the
back of these rallies are right wing outlets,
right side broadcasting and Newsmax. And
Newsmax didn't even cover Trump's Arizona rally,
so I don't know what they're complaining about.
Then Trump does the Q and on music and during
the Q and on music, he complains about commercial
airports, which, by the way, Trump doesn't ever go
to because he flies private. And it's weird, but
it's also kind of funny in a way. Check this out.
Speaker 3: A nation whose once revered airports
are dirty and a crowded mess. You sit and wait
for hours and then are notified that the plane
won't leave and they have no idea when they will.
Where ticket prices have tripled. They don't have
the pilots to fly the planes and they don't see
qualified air traffic controllers anymore.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Trump really very much
affected by just what goes on at airports.
That's absolutely something that is an issue
for him. Last one and then we'll move on very
briefly to a bonus clip. Trump is still talking
about Hillary's emails in 2022.
Speaker 3: But almost as bad,
crooked Hillary deleted 33,000 emails under
congressional subpoena. Subpoena. She asks in wash
them, although I do believe they're in the State
Department because it's very hard to get rid of
them. But they acid wash very expensive.
Speaker 1: I believe they're in the State
Department. Trump talks about emails as if they
are physical things. It's very interesting.
Speaker 3: Processes. Why nobody does it.
Speaker 1: She had four ideas in a box.
Speaker 3: And then pounded
her phones with hammers,
making them totally unrecognizable to
the naked eye. So she took those phones
and she pounded the hell out of them. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So there's the Hillary story. And
then here's just a bonus. Check this out. Here
is a woman theory. I forget this woman's first
name. She just makes up unemployment
numbers that are completely untrue,
but the crowd doesn't know any better.
Speaker 2: Under President Trump, we had a
little over 3% unemployment. Oh, okay. Do you know
the last time that happened is 1969 under Biden
and Obama were at 10%. Right. And even more now.
Speaker 1: That's completely untrue. We are at
3.5% unemployment right now, she says. We are at
over 10% unemployment. The crowd doesn't seem to
think much of it. These are just obvious lies.
But that crowd welcomes all of it. These rallies
continue to demonstrate the level of delusion
and disconnection from reality that these folks
have. And when we talk about, well, how do we get
them back? How do we get them back to sense it to
to common sense and normality? I don't know the
answer because they will accept whatever they are
told. Later in the show, we'll see some interviews
with the rally goers. All of these clips,
if you're listening today, you want to see them
in their full glory, destructive glory. We'll have
them on our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show. Very quick break and right back.